let's talk about the devil's advocate
okay the folks who are right now saying
well ripple deserves this because behind
closed doors they were doing x y z and
for the way ripple was formatted if i
remember
of that 100 billion right is it 100
billion tokens they might send it
correctly of which 80 they gifted 20
they kept right right today's market cap
is around 37 billion dollars the fully
diluted will be around 80 billion
dollars it's kind of where they are
today correct with numbers so
some people from the other side say well
listen these guys were kind of doing a
pump and dumb type of stuff behind
closed doors and they're going to be a
market manipulation and because there's
no regulation they can kind of do this
and you know they used to say that also
about uh uh john mcafee john mcafee
would say it's going to this let's go
into this let's go into this it would go
up he would sell then he would tell
people not to sell and i don't know
whether he did this or not but that was
a lot of criticism because we had mcafee
on as well well one of the big things
that you know we talked in the crypto
community our guys are like we love
ripple the technology we love ripple the
coin we love what it can do for you know
international you know uh money
transactions hate the people who created
it
so like that's that seems like why is
that though why why are people saying
that though well i think because when
you compare it to like bitcoin right
there was no pre-mine with bitcoin
and
you had people
allegedly could fairly mine for it and
it was open and was decentralized from
the beginning
they they believe that these executives
are enriching themselves but my answer
to that question is okay go after brad
garden house go after ripple why are you
going after the token why are you eight
years after the fact by going after the
teacher that put you know five hundred
dollars in the ripple yeah exactly i've
never met brad garland house never met
chris larson never met the
any of the people at ripple i'm no
ripple fan those two names you just so
if people don't know their founders i
think chris is the one that founded
ripple uh labs right he's one of the
co-founders as well yeah and and they
were sued independently now they the
thing about it pat is in this case after
a 30-month investigation the sec didn't
actually allege fraud
they investigated ripple for 30 months
there's no fraud alleged it is a strict
securities violation you didn't give
proper disclosures when you made these
transactions and and i say fine go after
them all right i'm not here to defend
them they've got way better lawyers than
me right to defend them but what you're
doing
when you go after the token itself in
the secondary market right you're let me
tell you something and i know this
because i've i've been communicating
with 60 000 people
it is an absolute fact that the first
time purchasers of xrp
58.2
of them had never heard of the company
ripple they've heard ripple the name but
they never heard of a company 58 percent
have never heard of this when they first
speculated they first spotted it
pure speculation yeah you know what they
do listen you go on you it was a number
three for a while it was number two
market cap but it's the top three market
cap somewhere like cryptocurrencies it's
25 cents so people look at it they see
bitcoin going up they're like hey i can
afford 25 cents right and so so they
were doing that and had no connection to
this company and so to to allege
that those people entered a common
enterprise with ripple and therefore
it's an investment contract is just it's
taking absurdity to the highest level
do you think that they attack a soft
target do you think that that they were
looking to set a precedent against the
tokens ripple made the mistake of
incorporating in the united states
and they went after people that they
didn't think like who pays you like like
they never thought that you know 60 000
coin holders would actually come
together communicate and formulate some
sort of defense against this they
thought they were going after a soft
target and that they were going to
create some case law that was going to
change the crypto landscape and then you
came in and you you you took a dump on
their front lawn well let me tell you i
think what we're talking about here the
people that you know in cryptocurrency
where and what pat said about people
don't like these executives or they
don't like the 80 percent being gifted
and holding back 20 percent if you read
the complaint even though they don't
allege fraud
they use fraud like language in the
complaint and it inflames people if you
don't like ripple and you're like oh
they're going after ripple i'm not
worried about it but when you read the
complaint and it says that all xrp
holders
are joined into a common enterprise with
each other and with ripple when they say
that the very nature of the token itself
is an investment contract with ripple
then it becomes very dangerous they're
using in my opinion this case to set the
precedent that you're talking about so
that if they're successful they can do
what you were saying pat and regulate
all the cryptocurrency so so so let's go
back to this sec lawsuit that uh uh uh
clayton you said clayton did right
before the day before he was done he
absolutely filed this lawsuit i think
it's december 20th of 2020 december
something of 2020 right after election
by the woman this thing kind of took
place
so
so the lawsuit is towards the exhaust
xrp holders
nothing to do with brad and chris is
that what you're saying or are they
going after brad and chris as well
separately no they're going after ripple
and brad and chris but they're being so
over broad in their language that
they're using that they're saying all
xrp even in the secondary market
that's being traded that all of that's
an unregistered security so one of these
62 000 that that's uh what did they get
in mail did they get and mail something
from the sec did they get
how do they know they're being part of
that lawsuit okay what happened was
basically and and this was forewarned
clayton and i have a letter i'm going to
give it to you because i just got it
from the sec after fighting them for
nine months
and threatening to sue them through a
freedom of information act but a former
fellow republican sec commissioner joe
grunfest on december 17th
sent a letter to clayton and the
commissioners and said
don't do this you are about to harm
innocent xrp holders and cause more
billions in losses than in any non-fraud
case in the history of this country they
warned them and they still filed it on
walking out the door and so what
happened is just as that former sec
commissioner warned he said listen if
you say the xrp is unregistered security
coinbase is trying to go public they're
not going to hold it they're not going
to keep it they're not going to trade it
and so the intermediaries the exchanges
and the platforms are going to delist it
and that's what happened and so coinbase
kraken binance
crypto.com they all said look i'm not
messing with the sec sec says the token
itself is a unregistered security we're
delisting it and we're not trading it
and so you have people
uh learn that way and many of these xrp
holders learned of this company named
ripple and these executives called brad
garland house and chris larson for the
first time when they got notice on their
wallet and coinbase that said pursuant
to the and it says i could show you on
my phone it says because of the sec
action against ripple we are suspending
all trading of xrp and let me tell you
how that impacts people pat
uh i don't know if you've ever heard of
i trust capital right it's basically an
ira for crypto and it's the biggest one
in the country and they allow you to
hold your crypto just like you can have
the bitcoin grayscale bitcoin trust in
an ira right
well they basically have frozen
all of the people's assets so xrp if
they want to trade it right now they
can't if they want to sell it because
xrp goes to five bucks and and take that
gain they can't this is robin hood gme
all over again i mean that's what you
can't buy or sell or trade right now you
not on coinbase on those there are a
couple exchanges like uphold that made
the decision that said this is ludicrous
our securities lawyers say there's not a
unregistered security we're comfortable
maintaining it but there's like one or
two out of 15 and the rest of them
delisted and but those individuals who
have that money that xrp it's frozen so
if they had a life altering event
right their mother-in-law needed to go
to a nursing home and they needed the
cash couldn't touch it can't touch it
yeah all waiting on this lawsuit to
happen couldn't tell you well that's
that's uh uh
uh that's how a lot of these
organizations get uh
you know negative
uh uh
reputation that they do sec types of
organizations what i'm talking about but
you know when you get a knock on the
door from sec that's a real knock yeah
it's not just anybody knocking on your
door that's a knock you gotta answer and
say here we go again so how much money
is ripple right now brad chris how much
are they using with legal teams
especially the killer the ridiculous
legal team that they have how much have
they already spent do you know i don't
know but i wouldn't be surprised if it's
at least a million and a half a month
okay million and a half a month is what
they're spending i mean that's that's me
guessing so so so in in full you know if
you were to say right now there's a few
things that can happen right with this
case
they can settle which a lot of people
are saying is probably going to end up
settling right let's just say it's going
to end up settling the sec comes and
let's settle you know 10 million bucks
50 million bucks 100 million bucks
whatever the number is that they settle
with right fine here's a check you move
on
and then the other one is to say they
release they just kind of say look we're
just going to let it go we're not going
to do anything right now
and uh we're not necessarily going to
settle with you
what is the consequences of both both
negative and positive
well i think it's very positive for
everyone if there is a settlement and
and
give you an example you could pick the
number
ripple owns 50 billion xrp it's in
escrow and each month one billion gets
released and they use some of it sell it
and then they put it back in escrow
that's 50 billion pat
imagine if xrp gets to five bucks
right
there were 250 billion dollars that's
significantly more than morgan stanley
and goldman sachs and so if that were to
happen and the scc were to be worried
about the precedent right the way this
case settles is gary ginsler is afraid
that an adverse ruling by the judge on
fair notice where she says listen you
can't go after him you let it happen for
eight years uh you didn't do anything
there's so much unclarity in the world
in this market uh you allowed them to do
moneygram you allowed it to go on
coinbase all those things
if that happens then that precedent
would be usable by cardano and xlm and
every other altcoin who doesn't want
that he doesn't want that makes sense so
if if that happens when that pressure
point takes place
then you could pick a number you could
if it goes to five bucks for example if
that happens
that's uh they could sell ten percent of
the monthly escrow which would give them
500 million dollars they could
settle for 500 million it would be a
huge public win for gary ginsler because
it would be one of the highest
sec settlements as long as as long as
they don't classify the token as a
security but but
that settlement won't happen unless they
do basically what was done for ether in
when bill hinman then the director of
corporation finance said you know what
we're going to set aside
the fundraising in the initial years but
today's token is not a security
we would need some kind of declaration
from the sec or the court for that
settlement to happen so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]